[Music]
Spencer Barnes makeup artist to Julianne
Hough Amber Heard and won Miss Megan
Marco thank you for joining us here
today thanks for having me tell me about
you and Megan first starting to work
together so Megan I met right before
suits started production megan is one of
the most kind immediately infectious
she's just kind of charm to her but
she's so down-to-earth you know her her
beauty's arresting like when you when
you meet her
even I was like wow you're really
stunning just as a person when you were
doing her makeup what kind of look was
she telling you she wanted to achieve
she loves beautiful skin to start with
so whenever I would work with her she
liked to highlight her fresh radiant
skin we would do often a very glowing
fresh face skin we would use earthy
tones colors that enhance her natural
beauty rather than a lot of obvious
color choices like purple or green or
blue you know we we would stick with
earthy tones peaches golds Browns a lot
of rich warm tones and that really
flattered her it helped her just look
radiant and fresh
we never did heavy makeup for Megan she
didn't really need it
have you seen her look change at all
since becoming a royal because she's had
to change a lot about her life since
becoming one I think some people thought
it would elevate and become stronger but
I think it's become more subtle and more
nuanced more she's kept that understated
refined sophisticated quality well she's
photographed so much and we like pore
over every photograph of her and video
for now and it almost looks to me
sometimes as though she's barely wearing
makeup you're right she I don't I don't
think she naturally is a person who
wants or needs or feels like she has to
put on a lot
she's softly defined and that's when she
shines her brightest and looks her best
yeah looking at that is it a look we
hear a lot that no makeup makeup look is
there actually a fair amount of makeup
going on to achieve that natural look or
do you look at her and think no that
really is Megan's skin there really is
kind of barely any product on there I
mean when you're seeing freckles and
you're seeing some of the natural
qualities of skin it's a good indicator
that there's very little on there and my
philosophy has always been one of the
things I'm known for as an artist is
helping people achieve beauty with
products that help bring out their
features you know I can paint I can do
bold glamour but I think when people say
wow you look stunning versus you have
really beautiful makeup on there's a big
difference in that kind of a compliment
yes so my goal is to help women look and
feel their best
ready to tell their stories and ready to
take on their day and it was a real
privilege and pleasure to be part of
Meghan's story
[Music]